[Music]
hey what's up guys
Samuel leaves here and this is
thoughtful first day and this week I'm
sat with my good friend Robert Joseph
and Robert Joseph he is a money mover so
he helps people invest overseas
absolutely fabulous guy really
knowledgeable so Robert great to have
you on the show thank you we've been
it's the first time that we've met today
but we've we've spoken on the phone
before you've been dealing with our guys
so why don't you just give us a little
bit of background as to what what do you
do and why is it so so vitally important
for anybody who's investing overseas
well in a nutshell as a regulated
brokerage in foreign exchange we help
individuals move money from one country
to another country so if for example
someone's in Hong Kong Australia and
they're investing in the UK we would
help them move their currency from hong
kong dollars into sterling or australian
dollars into sterling make it and they
need you know it's the equivalent to a
mortgage broker you can go straight to
the bank but if you go straight to the
bank you're gonna get a terrible deal
you're gonna get no guidance whatsoever
you're just going to be told yes no
whereas when you go to a broker you're
given the best advice the best rights
and it's the same with you when
absolutely I mean you know banks do a
lot of business they don't give anywhere
near the type of service that we give
the guidance that we give to help people
achieve good rates but timing and just
general service to make sure the money
comes into the country or we're taking
the money out the country and it ends up
getting to where it needs to be because
some of the stuff you do is so clever
like so clever so why don't you just
because there's an awful lot of people
right now investing in the UK there's
people coming from Singapore Hong Kong
Australia even America India and they're
investing in the UK why do you think
people are investing so much in the UK
in property right now despite all the
uncertainty that the Brits are feeling
great question I think it comes down to
returns I think these people believe
that they can't make the returns in
their own country we're better to go
we'll come over to United Kingdom and
there are so
any parts of the UK where these people
can invest and there's no shortage of
property and they're gonna get returns
that they can't get in their own country
they're really happy to come and invest
in the UK yeah yeah so I mean what I
mean right now in the UK there's there's
so many great opportunities and it's
funny because Warren Buffett says when
people are scared that's when you should
be greedy and when people are greedy
that's when you should be scared and now
there's news articles going out talking
about things like section 24 going on
about briggsie and some of these things
it's like old news right like section 24
that's that stuff so 2016 yeah you know
and there's ways around it but they're
bad news cells so while people are then
being real super scared that's when
people are coming in from Hong Kong and
Australia and making serious money in I
think it's opportunity you know these
people if they've got money and they're
not getting a return in their own
country and they've identified the UK
and parts of the UK they want to bring
the money into the UK that's where we
step in and we help make the transaction
very efficient very cost effective and
they get the money from where it starts
to where it needs to get to yeah and
you're usually dealing with pretty smart
people presumably that research their
own country research the UK whereabouts
in robots in the UK are people
particularly investing all over I mean
we do a lot of business and and I see
people that tell me that they go to
Liverpool they go to Glasgow I mean it
can be any region probably from
Birmingham upwards which you've got
properties in Liverpool yeah so so talk
to me Robert about how it works moving
money from one country to another you
know because you don't even in a bank
dear well in terms of using our services
you're right you don't need a bank
account somebody opens an account with
us very simple process takes five
minutes and there are clients of central
effects then I can talk to them about
what they're looking to do and we can
understand a little bit about how much
money they've got to move when they need
to move it by and we can work out a
strategy that can help them maximize the
return of achieving the most amount of
sterling that they need
in the time frame and hopefully
minimizing risk of currency fluctuation
so the accounts open we talked about the
strategy and then we then say right
we're going to follow the strategy
through and we're going to agree a deal
when we agree a deal it's on the phone
because our lines are recorded because
we're FCI regulated and it's a
transaction done once it's agreed the
client receives a contract note by email
within five minutes confirming what
we've sold the currency that we've
bought at the rate and we need the money
in by the settlement dates banking
structions are on the contract notes as
well and then it's all with the client
to make sure we receive the funds in two
to three days
and that's that that's great and I know
I mean we work with really good mortgage
brokers you as a money mover as well a
lot of people that are investing in the
UK from overseas they'll buy often they
bought their first house in cash that
they because it's just easy even if it's
a really cheap property like 30 40 50
grams just to buy their first and then
they can always add value to it
refinance it but then later it will be
much easier getting a mortgage and I
think a big point here is confidence you
know an overseas investor who lives five
ten thousand miles away they want to
know that their money is going to arrive
to where it needs to get to whether it's
going to be to their bank account
whether it's going to be to a solicitor
the money's got to get there and it's
got to get there in one piece on time so
any confidence and if their first steal
and even buying property if their first
deal is building confidence and starting
small they see it from start to finish
work they then go back for the second
deal and it might be 60 70 thousand and
then the third deal might be a hundred
thousand and it's just building up the
experience with the confidence that kind
of helps them I suppose feel a sense of
achievement yeah and something that we
teach people to do is you know rubber is
we teach people how to buy property
using none of their own money and let me
ask you as as an overseas investor have
you ever worked with people whereby they
have bought a property in the UK but
they've done it using an angel investor
or someone else's funds all the time I
think in terms of international
investors it's a mixture
you've got international investors who
have their own funds and you've got the
other side that need the angel investor
and the process is as simple but the
investor needs to go and find the angel
investor and then once the angel
investor sends the money to the actual
person that's going to be buying the
property the funds come in it's the same
process and that's why we work so well
together because we'll train people how
to find a good property how to get an
angel investor how to put a Power Team
where to buy and then you come in and
make it all happen seamlessly yeah
absolutely but it's important for for
the you know the international investor
wants to get a good service and they
want to get a good rate and we combine
the two and then they become happy and
hopefully they become happy that they
come back and do the second transaction
and the third or how many how many
properties they you know physically feel
they want to buy within their their
strategy for themselves it's funny as
well because sometimes people think you
know how on earth would you buy a
property so far away from home
you know surely you need to be there to
keep it on it if there's any problem but
I think that if you need to be there to
keep an eye on it if there's a problem
then that's a pretty bad plan a because
that what that means is that means that
for there will be problems and you're
going to be the person that's managing
it which is not financial freedom that
actually a rope around your neck
so the key trick is having a really good
Power Team a really good strategy and
buying in such a way whereby it's true
passive income where you don't need to
do anything and if you're doing that
then it doesn't matter what even what
could treat your in yeah no absolutely
and I think you know you hit the nail on
the head there Power Team you know we
like to feel that we are part of an
international investors power team and
they use us when they need to move money
into the UK or they've made money on a
project for example they've had a
successful flip or they've built up a
nice pot through rental income and they
want to bring money back out the UK and
then we're just doing the reverse talk
to me about I know when I was in the
States you were watching my challenge
closely talk to me about what you said
to me when we're messaging each other
about how I could potentially be clever
with the exchange rate yeah I mean it's
interesting so you've secured you've
secured your property $75,000 fantastic
a great documentary by the way really
really good you've secured the property
great business but you're not paying for
it until 5 years time yeah
now as we spoke about within 5 years the
exchange rate is going to move it isn't
going to stay at the 1.3 1.3 one level
that is now to buy dollars so you've got
a take of you the market can go down the
market can go up we when we tell the the
investors when they're buying abroad we
always want the market to be as high as
possible for them so in your case the
higher the market the more dollars
you're gonna get for your money so if
the market goes back to one point for
one point four to one point four three
where it's been in the last 12 months
you're going to get more dollars but if
the market drops to one point two one
point two five you're gonna get less
dollars so when we were chatting I was
saying that we need to pick a point in
the next maybe one to three years
certainly before the option is up for
either I take it up or I don't we need
to pick a point where we're happy where
the market is and we make the exchange
and we secure the US dollars and they'll
just sit in the account and wait until
you need to send them out to America
it's really clever because that way that
way you're not buying the property for
five years but you're putting the money
ready yeah when it's the best when you
get to that way you're gonna get way
more money more property for your money
absolutely I'm sweeping on a lease
option as well presumably it's trending
it's going to go up yeah you're you're
winning all round
absolutely and I think probably part of
the service there is that when we guide
people I'll talk to them about this is
what you can do but if you do nothing
you're running the risk and when you run
the risk in the currency market which is
the the biggest market globally several
trillion traded every single day but
when you when you run the risk of doing
nothing and these markets go up and down
when it comes to the point of actually
right I now leave my seventy five
thousand dollars we don't know where the
market is going to be so real
a real big part of my job is to reduce
the risk take the risk away as much as
possible for investors because there's
another thing is if someone lives inside
Hong Kong or Australia which is where a
lot of investors at the moment are
investing in the UK if they're an angel
if they've got an angel investor and
let's say that got any money but they
really want to invest in the UK so they
borrow $50,000 he's got what it's called
fifty thousand Australian dollars they
then invest that in the UK but they've
told their angel investor that they're
going to pay them back once they
refinance so I want to say whatever it
is so they'll pay them back in two years
if the exchange rate changes could that
mess them up and what not how do you
protect that it's a conversation we have
with investors all the time particularly
when an angel is involved and
particularly when the term is 12 months
or 24 months at the angel wants their
money back so we'll talk to the investor
about the different options available to
again reduce risk so they know how many
dollars at what rate they're gonna get
coming back and we do that through
what's called a forward contract I won't
go into too much detail about it but
it's very specific for that type of
investor that's borrowing money and
again the most important part there is
it reduces risk so the investor knows
his rate sending the money back to
Australia or Hong Kong or ever it's
going so he's not he's not gonna have
any nasty surprises lobbies not gonna
have any nasty surprises that and let me
tell you you know we're we're we've had
people come to us and they haven't gone
ahead and actually locked in a rate with
a forward contract because they wanted
to see what the market was going to do
there's been some unhappy experiences
because we just don't know you know
brexit Donald Trump China Chad we'll
trying to China trade wars you know it
all it all takes its toll on the market
and the markets move up and they move
down they're gonna go in your favour out
your favor so one of the big education
points for us is making sure we minimize
risk both ways yeah that's great it's
really cool having people on the show
like yourself because you
personally firsthand see people buying
property with none of their own money
all the time and sometimes people think
it's good to be true or that doesn't
sound possible but as professionals my
mortgage brokers list yourself that just
see it happening and it's just like an
everyday occurrence I was talking to
Robert Kiyosaki about this just the
other day he was also on my channel and
I said to him you know what would you
say to people that say that buying
property we've known if your own money
is too good to be true it's a pipe dream
and he said well why would I want to
disagree with them you know there's no
need to argue it's just a case of
getting done but how important do you
think education is in all of this
because obviously you can make a lot of
money in property UK's really good how
important do you think it is - yeah I
think you know again training education
is paramount I think what you're doing
is wonderful and you're really giving
people a great chance in terms of making
them believe that they can go and find
properties and starting with no money my
part the education is crucial for the
timing the service minimizing risk we've
got to get money into the UK at the best
possible price at the best possible time
and making sure the client understands
the service and at some point take the
money out the UK so education is the key
for me it's understanding the client
understanding their circumstances and
making sure that they fully understand
what we do and the strategies that are
available to them and then we try and
meet a match and get the two together
and I think once they then understand
what they should be doing they make the
decisions we give the guidance but they
make the decisions but through education
and hopefully those decisions are the
right ones for them and they're happy
with everything that goes on yeah what
do you think about the UK what I know
you think it's a great time to buy in
the UK right now why do you what do you
think that I think you know an
international investor isn't going to
get the same returns in his own country
or her own country as they are in the UK
just because interest rates for example
property prices can be astronomical in
certain countries they identify the UK
as the hub where they can get you know
are oh is that are much much higher and
not have to do an awful lot of work if
they've got the right power team in
place and I also believe there's so many
parts of the UK so many pockets where
with the right power team they can go
and invest into these areas return on
investment is great they're happy and
then it can work once twice three four
five times it can be as many times as
they want to or it can just be a one-off
yeah but it's opportunity and it's a
return on their money that they can't
get in their own country really
interesting because I guess every
country's got its pros and cons like
when I was in the state's I was actually
really tempted about putting my own
money into some properties out there as
you know but then I'm sure if I was in
some countries I'd run amok I'd run a
mile but the bottom line is wherever you
live in the world it doesn't necessarily
mean that you can do it in your hometown
or even in your country but you can do
this you can make money in property
wherever you are in the world but not to
say in your straight I mean where I live
it's not the best place in the world but
I invest my investor outside of my own
town and you can the fact you can do it
outside of your own country is really
cool and it's so good to know people
like you that come out like that
possible thank you and I think you know
ago we said it before it's that it's
giving them the belief you know and then
it's showing them from start to finish
how it works and that it can happen and
I find with international investors once
they do it once and they've seen the
whole process through it makes the
second and third time so much easier
that's so true Robert thank you so much
for coming on I look forward to
continued doing business with you and
you've been awesome
Samuel thank you appreciate you sighs
all right so that was mr. Robert Joseph
if you've been inspired please do like
and share the video don't forget to
comment below if you've got any
questions or thoughts and I'll do my
best to answer every single one until
next time peace out have a wonderful day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]